five million
eight hundred and fifty-one it did not
come as a surprise
president johary museveni has maintained
a decisive lead
against his opponents from the start of
the vote count
the electoral commission declares yahweh
russell
tibu kaguta elected president of the
republic of uganda
the president addressed the nation after
his victory was declared
and say despite attempts by some
individuals to tamper with the biometric
identification kits
the election was largely free and fair i
congratulate you
for turning up in big numbers
and voting for the candidates
and for the parties of your choice i
think
this may turn out to be the most
cheating free
election since 1962
supporters of the 76 year old incumbent
turned out to celebrate
every gander must support his excellence
recently he's the one who knows us
the electoral commissioners say they've
done their best under the circumstances
but already
the results have been rejected by bobby
wein who has said
he has evidence of widespread illegal
irregularities including
rigging in favor of president johari
museveni
his team members say they are
considering
moving to court to challenge the results
there has also been
other forms of rigging that are not
restricted
to fortification of declaration forms
including chasing away of agents at the
polling station
including forcing people to vote in the
open
yet under the lawyers supposed to have a
sacred barrel
the results saw wine received nearly 35
of the vote and his party the national
unity platform
has garnered a sizable number of
legislative seats
however he told al jazeera that his
movements have been restricted
and visitors including journalists have
been blocked from accessing his compound
by soldiers surrounding his home
security officials say
they had information that he was
planning to declare himself winner
there's also been heavy deployment of
police and the military in the capital
and other urban areas perceived to be
opposition strongholds
the winner may have been declared but
the country
remains on edge catherine sawyer
al-jazeera
kampala